>>> Russia's most prominent
opposition leader alexei navalny
had already been living in
hellish conditions, locked up in
penal colony often in solitary
confinement.
He's also been denied medical
care.
Well, today navalny's lawyers
says he's been moved to an even
harsher callsary confinement
facility for a maximum period of
six months.
Navalny himself tweeted about
the torment and not being able
to see them for eight months and
counting.
Well, hardships make one tougher
though I don't understand why
this should apply to my
children, too.
Tonight one of his children is
here.
Dasha, I appreciate you being
back with us.
I'm sorry for this latest news.
When you heard that your father
would be moved to solitary cune
finement, I mean what goes
through your mind?
>> Well, first of all, thank you
so much, Anderson, for having me
again.
To answer your question in short
what went through my mind is
that Vladimir Putin and the
federal penalty service continue
to practice their lawlessness
and are slowly torturing and
killing my father.
Last time you and I talked we
were asking for doctors to see
him because he had -- there was
a big flu problem in the prison
and there still is.
Since then they've deliberately
infected him with the flu by
intentionally placing a sick
person in his cell.
They prescribed my father with
antibiotics, which may seem
fine, but it was such a huge
amount -- such a high dose that
he lost 7 kilos or pounds I
think 15 or 16.
You and I talked a few weeks ago
and losing 15 pounds in that
time is incredibly concerning.
They are not actually treating
his flu or his back problems.
And on top of his health
problems, the prison ward just
moved him as you said to another
colony and today they were
supposed to release him from his
penalty cell, and it was his
11th term.
And instead of moving him --
instead they moved him to a
penalty cell-type facility of
maximum possible term of six
months.
There are no calls, no visits,
no human conditions.
He's allowed to write 35 minute
per day with a pen and paper,
and he's allowed to have two
books.
These actions are clearly an
open strategy to destroy my
father's physical health and
maybe mental, too, by all means.
And the reason why I called
Putin out is because there's
absolutely no way the colony
would take these drastic
measures without having a nudge
from the Moscow government.
And since he had 11 terms in the
penal colony before, I can't be
certain that they -- they'll
stick to the six months maximum
term in the few facility.
>> Was your family given any
warning I mean by the
authorities that this was
coming?
Or do these things just happen
and you learn about it
afterward?
>> No, absolutely not.
They never tell us what's
happening.
My dad was transferred three
times in the past few years
without absolutely any knowledge
of where he is or direction that
he's going.
There's absolutely no
communication from the colony,
from the government about my
father's conditions.
>> So he's only allowed to write
for three to five minutes a day,
and he's allowed two books.
>> 35, yes.
>> Wow.
I mean, can he get through this?
Can he -- can he survive six
months in solitary confinement
in these conditions in his cell?
>> I mean we have to stay
hopeful.
I would say for those watching
right now -- and thank you for
watching -- and wondering how
you can help, there are two
things.
The first is the power of social
media and spreading the word is
incredibly impactful even though
some may not think so.
You know, follow me or my dad on
social media.
Follow the anti-corruption
foundation on social media to
find out what's happening.
Watch and spread the documentary
"Navalny" and tell your friends
about the situation.
Create awareness.
No person should be in prison
for simply not agreeing with the
government especially an
authoritarian government.
And it's a critical aspect for
any democratic country or
system.
And the second perhaps more I
would say politically effective
is call your or e-mail your
local officials and ask how are
they imposing sanctions and what
are they doing to free Alex nee
navalny.
>> I appreciate your time.
>> Thank you so much for having
me.
>> For more on the story how